let us see well my first thought is we
could play queen a1 check the King moves
we could grab that night but so what
look at the material white is up two
minor pieces White has two bishops and
our bishops are long gone
so trying to just regain a knight is not
going to cut it I think I see the answer
and oh is it just as simple as that
somebody saying Knight takes d5
somebody's sending 95 but another thing
I'm looking into is just I'm looking
into another move of a quiet move keep
in mind that this is the only square the
King has available so some of my
attention is centered around trying to
control this square in one way to maybe
do that is to have the knight on this
square but playing it here right away
well it just gets captured however what
if after rookie - we have Bishop takes
rook well let me stay like this after if
rook e - is played how do you defend
against the main thread on a1 if you
touch that if you move the night you get
mated with rook moving the knight would
allow the Queen to watch over a1 but
moving the knight allows the rook to
enter the scene on b1 and that's going
to be TKO rookie - cuts out that one
flight Square and if after Bishop takes
rook after Knight e5 we have that same
story I believe same story knight on e4
controlling this flight square once
again mate thread on a1 how do you
defend it you move the knight yet again
rook b1 I think that this is going to be
the move now one last thing I'm now
checking for I believe that this is the
solution the last thing that I'm
checking for is does Bishop check here
do anything and I believe it does now we
get to probably just move our king
wherever we want
h8 f8 no probably just h8 just to avoid
Queen checks here so that's not a
problem
what are your thoughts some quick votes
coming in I've probably skewed many of
your thoughts by suggesting rookie 2 but
I think that that is it sneaky move
rookie to Knight takes d5 looks
appealing because it's hitting the Queen
it's picking up a pond but there's one
reason that I'm kind of discounting that
is because of well what is it doing it's
though there's so many well not so many
but I guess there's a lot of different
moves that could be played here for
white rookie to I think we're gonna go
with that hopefully this is right rook e
2 is co-rect and I believe now the
follow-up is not check and then here
with the fork but to first just control
this square I think this does the trick
and the e4 is correct and that's it
problem is solved you do not have to go
any further that are not letting us play
through this one but that's pretty much
it a mate ensues on a1 or b1 unavoidable
Queen a3 just take the Queen back the
same thing happening B 3 a1 would then
be threat all right very cool